llegó el momento de hablar de economía
en directo américa por ello le doy la
bienvenida a mi compañero jorge hurtado
jorge tal como lo adelantábamos
iniciamos en reinounido que estrenará
primera ministra pero como recibirá la
economía list trust bueno esa economía
se encuentra en su peor estado desde
1970 los datos muestran un gobierno
encaminado a una potencial recesión y
con el costo de la vida más alto desde
los años 80 uno de los temas que más
preocupa a los británicos es el costo de
la factura eléctrica que podría aumentar
hasta en un 80 por ciento en octubre
esto es casi el triple de lo registrado
hace un año atrás dijo hoy que su
gobierno buscará la reducción de
impuestos para impulsar la economía y
una de las primeras medidas que
anunciaría este martes sería congelar
los precios energéticos según algunos
medios locales esta propuesta fue hecha
hace semanas por el laborismo y
rechazada en ese momento y hasta este
fin de semana por los conservadores pero
las iniciativas de trozos como bajar
impuestos hasta por 27 mil millones de
libras aumento del presupuesto de
defensa y salud equilibrio fiscal entre
otros
a los mismos tories y a los mercados
este será un tema del que seguramente
vamos a hablar durante toda la semana a
profundidad sin duda alguna jorge y
entre otros temas la organización de
países productores de petróleo y aliados
anunciaron un recorte en la producción
mundial
bueno este recorte se da mientras
aumentan los temores de recesión que
ayudan a bajar los precios del crudo la
decisión supone un retroceso en el
aumento de 100 mil barriles diarios que
se había producido en septiembre es
importante señalar que los productores
de petróleo como arabia saudi se han
resistido al llamado de bombear más
petróleo con el fin de reducir los
precios de la gasolina y aliviar la
carga para los consumidores los temores
de recesión bajaron los precios desde
los máximos de junio de más de 120
dólares el barril esto afectó la cerca
de los países de la opep pero con este
anuncio ocurrió el efecto contrario el
crudo estadounidense subió un 3,3 por
ciento hasta 88 82 dólares por barril
mientras que el brent la referencia
internacional subió 37 por ciento hasta
hasta 95 dólares tras esta decisión
empezamos ahora a américa latina porque
el rechazo a la nueva constitución donde
chile podría derivarse en mayor
inversión en el sector de cobre en ese
país bueno teniendo la referencia de
moderar el aumento de los impuestos se
podrían desbloquear millones en
inversión para este sector según
bloomberg en línea la posibilidad de
mayores impuestos y nuevas normas
medioambientales llegó a las empresas
mineras a suspender algunas inversiones
una de ellas bien
ruth anunció en marzo inversiones por 10
mil millones de dólares siempre y cuando
el país no cambiará demasiado las reglas
chile cuenta con una cuarta parte del
cobre que se extrae en el mundo pero
tras el no el presidente gabriel boric
reiteró su compromiso de intentar
cambiar la constitución porque venezuela
la inflación no da tregua bueno esto
según el independiente observatorio
venezolano de finanzas la inflación
mensual en agosto se disparó hasta el
17,3 por ciento 12 puntos más que en
julio de este modo la inflación anual o
sea la de agosto de 2021 comparada con
agosto de este año se ubicó en un 153
por ciento en venezuela la organización
asegura que el precio de la canasta
alimentaria se ubicó en 371 dólares
dando un aumento del 21 66 por ciento
respecto al año anterior el banco
central de venezuela quien brinda las
cifras oficiales sobre el comportamiento
de la inflación aún no publica los datos
de agosto venezuela salió en diciembre
pasado de una hiperinflación en la que
entró en 2017 que duró cuatro años esto
redujo el valor del bolívar la moneda
oficial por lo que la ciudadanía empezó
a usar de manera no oficial el dólar
estadounidense en un intento por
proteger sus ingresos porque finalizamos
en argentina los productores ven con
cautela el dólar usted me corregirá el
dólar soya dólar soja dólar soja dólar
roja e impulsa el gobierno para captar
las divisas bueno esta medida es
promovida precisamente por el ministro
del nuevo ministro de finanzas y
economía en sergio massa con el objetivo
de aumentar las reservas monetarias del
país suramericano el gobierno anunció la
creación de un nuevo régimen cambiario
que busca acumular unos cinco mil
millones de dólares procedentes de la
liquidación de la soja los exportadores
la principal de esta principal materia
prima de ese país podrán vender los
dólares de sus envíos al exterior a una
tasa de 2 cientos pesos por dólar más
lucrativa que la tasa oficial que de 139
por dólar sin incluir los impuestos
algunos productores critican la medida
porque según ellos sólo beneficiará a
los sectores concentradores y
exportadores generando una
discriminación con el resto de
actividades productivas de ese país
rodrigo muchas gracias por la
información económica nos vemos más
adelante para actualizar estas noticias
y ustedes televidentes también gracias
por acompañarnos a continuación santiago
ariztía con el debate
[Música]